Фантастичні умови для підприємців, якщо врахувати
актуальний стан речей, коли банківський сектор
пропонує їм кредити від 20, 30 а то і 40% річних.
Команда президента Зеленського декларує
амбітну мету зростання економіки до 5-9% річних
і дуже розраховує на дрібних та середніх підприємців,
тому й виділяє на дешеві кредити для них
два мільярди гривень як компенсацію банкам
за зниження відсоткової ставки.  Банки кредитують
інвестиційні проекти, зокрема, придбання,
модернізацію основних засобів,
ремонт виробничих приміщень.
- Ця програма розрахована не на те, щоб узяти гроші
і щось купити і кудись втекти.
Ця програма розрахована на людей, які хочуть
узяти на себе відповідальність,
створити власну справу, робочі місця.
Ця програма для сильних, сміливих, рішучих людей.
Сильних та рішучих в Україні, схоже, багато.
Відповідно і бажаючих взяти такі кредити - теж.
В уряді кажуть: головне - написати цікавий
бізнес-план і підкріпити розрахунками, які погодить
банк. Солодка на перший погляд пропозиція,
каже цей керівник бізнес-інкубатора. Його бізнесу
потрібні ресурси для розвитку нового напрямку,
але не факт, що нова програма дешевих кредитів - саме для нього.
- Цікава відсоткова ставка, але цікаві й умови.
Адже ми, підприємці, як звикли?
Є відсоткова ставка, але є й купа підводних каменів
під нею. Треба уважно розібратися.
Власники цієї київської продакшн-студії -
серед 17 тисяч підприємців, які подали свої заявки
на кредитування в перший тиждень дії програми
і вже розібралися з усіма підводними каменями.
Студія заснована 5 років тому, наразі це класичне
підприємство середнього бізнесу, яке може надати багато послуг.
Музиканти записують та знімають тут треки.
Камери постійно задіяні у зйомках різних проектів.
Не простоюють і студії, де знімають фотосесії.
Студія хоче стати більше потужною, аби
претендувати на співпрацю з іноземними продюсерами,
які останнім часом багато знімають в Україні.
Для цього конче необхідний потужний сервер для відеомонтажу.
За новою програмою підприємці можуть отримати
півтора мільйона гривень під 7% річних, тому що
створюють два додаткові робочі місця.
Студія відповідає усім умовам кредитування:
більше року на ринку, менше 50 працівників,
річний дохід не перевищує 50 мільйонів гривень.
Але все-таки скористатися кредитом студія
навряд чи зможе. Їй зовсім не підходять умови,
заявлені банком, адже щоб отримати необхідний
кредит, треба мати заставу: квартиру, будинок
чи машину вартістю удвічі вищою, тобто
три мільйони гривень.  Співзасновник студії
Олександр Мотлюк жартує, що таких апартаментів
вони всі разом ще не заробили. Та навіть якщо б і
мали, швидше за все, не взяли б цей кредит.
- Якщо ми, наприклад, дамо в заставу автомобіль,
його потрібно застрахувати. Це мінімум 7%.
Плюс одноразова комісія банку в 1%. Також сюди
треба врахувати витрати на оцінку майна,
тому, скажімо, ефективною вже ця відсоткова
ставка в 5-7-9 вже не буде. Вона  збільшиться
принаймні на 8 -10%, тому ми будемо мати
насправді той самий кредит у 16%.
Не влаштовує підприємців і те, що банк
відмовляється кредитувати телевізійну техніку,
яка придбана за кордоном, хоча там вона дешевша
і якісніша. Банк також вимагає, щоб купівля була
здійснена в одній компанії. У випадку телевізійної
техніки це майже неможливо.
Майже така сама історія з технікою в аграрному секторі,
який купує здебільшого імпортні машини.
Фермерка з Полтавщини Катерина Скрильник
хоче взяти дешевий кредит задля створення
так званої демоферми. Це будуть майданчики
для навчання студентів-фермерів. А також придбати
нове поголів’я корів. Їй потрібен саме такий кредит:
під низькі відсотки і на 5 років.
- Відсоткова ставка дуже приваблива.
Я на даний момент користуюся 26% річних.
Підводне каміння… Дуже засмутило,  що
живе поголів’я тварин під цю програму кредитування не підлягає.
Жінка сподівається, що для аграрного сектора,
на успіх якого дуже сподіваються в уряді,
створять окремі програми дешевих кредитів.
Співзасновник студії Олександр Мотлюк вважає,
що у програму дешевих кредитів треба внести
і пропозиції щодо лізингу техніки.
- Було дуже гарно, тому що,
окрім купівлі обладнання, є його обслуговування.
Підприємці , які платять ПДВ, -
для них це ще вигідніше,
тому ми чекаємо на появу подібних програм.
Опитані DW підприємці схильні вважати, що
програмою дешевих кредитів, швидше за все,
зможуть скористатися не всі підприємці-початківці.
Їм виконати умови банку дуже складно, адже треба
не лише надати заставу, вдвічі дорожчу
за суму кредиту, а ще й на 20% співфінансувати
інвестиційний проект власним коштом.
Такі відгуки від бізнесу прем’єр Олексій Гончарук
обіцяв врахувати. Прем'єр також пообіцяв, що
програма дешевих кредитів буде діяти упродовж
наступних щонайменше трьох років, допоки банки
самі, без допомоги держави, не почнуть надавати
бізнес-кредити під 5, 7 і 9% річних.